por clippers antes un pan
de hecho no todas las personas están
sujetas a vivir un confinamiento de la
misma manera
a sus 25 años soy un sufre de una
psicosis llamada trastorno
esquizoafectivo se trata de la
combinación de síntomas de trastornos
del estado de ánimo con síntomas de
esquizofrenia
hay momentos en los que me siento
inseguro eso puede desencadenar algunos
de mis síntomas
que pueden ser trastornos alucinatorios
o múltiples percepciones sensoriales es
johnson soy el de triple
estas fases de ruptura del equilibrio
psicológico tienen un nombre la
descompensación juliá ha sido internado
varias veces en un hospital psiquiátrico
también ha seguido un tratamiento
farmacológico fuerte hoy se siente mejor
pero con la crisis sanitaria los viejos
demonios vuelven a surgir
me molesta cuando ve películas cuando
pasa todo el día viendo series o se
encierra en su habitación no se va lejos
sin decir a dónde va cuando no responde
cuando pierde su teléfono
si me ha pasado una manera de huir de
una rutina a veces muy sofocante como lo
es en este momento en medio de una
epidemia que parece no tener fin
y tuve muchas relaciones con personas
que volvieron a enfermarse que se
descompensaron de nuevo que recayeron
que hablaron de suicidarse como
voluntaria de la unaf am hice muchas
escuchas telefónicas
la una fama es la unión nacional de
familias y amigos de personas con
enfermedades psíquicas
maquillan es su presidente según ella la
próxima bola será psiquiátrica
recibí varios testimonios de familias de
personas con familiares que se
suicidaron recientemente no sé cómo la
psiquiatría con los medios con los que
cuenta hoy va a poder enfrentar estos
síndromes depresivos trastornos del
sueño ansiedad según la organización
mundial de la salud una de cada cuatro
personas presenta algún trastorno
psíquico a lo largo de su vida por lo
general en la adolescencia